[Musique]
jean paul huchon bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors le
président de la république on le disait
doit donc prendre la parole ce soir le
variant delta progresse sur le
territoire il y aura plus de vingt mille
cas début août si nous n'agissons pas a
prévenu hier le ministre de la santé
alors face à cette situation vous est ce
que vous êtes favorable à une
vaccination obligatoire des siennes des
soignants il en saura cas ce soir
alors nous avons un problème tu es
christus jean paul huchon a un petit
problème technique
on va voir s'il est réglée voilà c'est
bon je vous demandais donc est ce que
vous vous êtes favorable à la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
n'attendait réponse ce soir avec la
prise de parole des manuels macro je
reste peu favorable à ces deux mesures
parce que les soignants d'avoir le
sentiment d'être dans le viseur du
gouvernement alors que londres a ldd
flore des puits moment pendant très
longtemps je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
passer par une obligation qui légalement
dernier pas facile à mettre en oeuvre
mais bien entendu s'il est avéré qu'il y
à des contaminations à travers les à
lussan skalli et deux au fait il va
peut-être falloir y réfléchir mais aller
au delà même des soignants me paraît pas
très raisonnable est en tout cas donne
un sentiment de tori taris mme qui va
être très mal supporté
en réalité ce n'est pas possible c'est
ce qu'on vit en ce moment un jour tout
va bien ça va ça par l'économie
repartira puis un jour tout va mal tout
un coup on va avoir dans milk avec style
à moi je pense que la communication
gouvernementale n'est pas clair et il le
président aurait intérêt à la rendent
plus clair ce soir si c'est possible à
fixer un horizon
afficher des perspectives parce que là
on est ballottée d'un côté à l'autre et
au fond c'est le virus qui décide de
notre avenir et notre situation
alors jean paul huchon envoyé à propos
de la vaccination obligatoire ce qu'avec
l'arrêt l'ancien ministre et médecin
bernard kouchner
c'était hier dans les colonnes du jdd
ceux qui face à ce virus choisissent de
se battre individuellement sont sinon
des déserteurs du moins des alliés du
virus la vaccination n'est pas un sujet
personnel l'a refusée c'est une trahison
il faudrait une loi alors refusé la
vaccination c'est une trahison il faudra
une loi
comment vous réagissez à ces propos le
goûter c'est un peu insupportable j'aime
bien bernard est un ami et ses rames est
qu un peu insupportable ce vocabulaire
guerre désertion acceptera tout ça na
entretien climat dans ce pays qui me
paraît plus en plus inquiétant je crois
que si vraiment il est nécessaire de
vacciner
on va le faire je pense le territoire
des antilles paquin moi je suis vacciné
j'ai aucun souci avec ça mais parce que
c'est une ambiance disons plus en plus
autoritaire sur un pays qui est quand
même épris de liberté alors le pass
sanitaire qui sera également question ce
soir alors est-ce qu'il faut l'élargir
selon vous aux hôtels au restaurant est
ce que ça peut être aussi un bon moyen
d'inciter les français à se faire
vacciner quel est votre regard sur ce
pass vaccine air vaccinale sanitaires
commencent à dire comme l'a dit roselyne
bachelot
hier c'est pas très compliqué une fois
qu'on l'a on l'a alors maintenant dans
le détail fille à chaque fois qu'on va
chez d'un commerçant ou dans un
restaurant il faut le montrer
là ça devient très très
des baisants l'air sec ce qui se passe
en ce moment c'est cette impression
petit à petit qu'on revient aux
privations de liberté qu'on a connu à
lauras ne fallait pas les conflits ne
fallait attendre fallait plus dur au
départ et ce qui ne va pas c'est cette
espèce de stop and go permanent et là il
va vraiment falloir sifflet sinon une
fin du moins au début de récréation
parce que certains on l'entend emploie
ce terme de dictature sanitaires alors
c'est un peu ce que ce que vous nous
dites cette privation de liberté où 121
petit tout de même et reste trop fort
dictionnaire je pense qu'on peut pas
parler dicature sanitaire c'est pas dieu
c'est la communication gouvernementale
et pas tu peux adapter à ce que nous
vivons en ce moment elle est mal faite
elle est comment dirais je elle suit les
films cités qui ne sont pas acceptables
pour le public mais par contre qu'on
puisse avoir besoin d'un pass à iter
quand on va attendre des rassemblements
si c'est pas seulement aux restaurants
et des choses comme ça à mes temps des
rassemblements en particulier je pense
que c'est justifié et de toute manière
ça conduira je pense les gens à
davantage se faire vacciner
je dirais volontairement ce qui est
quand même mieux
dans un pays comme le nôtre n'est pas en
corée du nord alors autre sujet attendu
ce soir lors de la location du président
allocution du président c'est la réforme
des retraites
voyez ce qu'on m'a dit anne hidalgo la
maire de paris en plus d'être en
contradiction directe avec un engagement
pris lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle
cette perspective est profondément
injuste une mesure d'âge frapperait en
effet avec une acuité particulière les
professions exposées à la pénibilité
celle là même que nous avons applaudi à
20h pendant des mois une mesure ajuste
donc pour anne hidalgo vous rejoignez
ses propos oui tout à fait je pense que
c'est d'abord ça ne correspond pas à
l'état de la situation parce que on a
dit quoi qu'il en coûte et saisira donc
maintenant d'un
le coup il faudrait se remettre à
redevenir rigoureux et c'est alors que
la reprise n'a pas eu lieu
qu' on n'est pas sûr qu'elle ait lieu
aussi rapidement du fait de la poursuite
de l'épidémie
non je pense que en plus et c'est en
effet une trahison des engagements pour
tomber on voulait changer le mode de
calcul de la retraite amène on ne parle
que d'augmenter l'âge je crois que ça ne
passera pas du tout et c'est très très
inquiétant de voir la totalité des
syndicats y compris la cfdt qui avait
essayé de réfléchir au sujet et la
plupart des hommes politiques le dire
mais aussi même le patronat donc ça ne
va pas passer
je ne sais pas ce que monsieur minc on
peut faire ce que le président veut
faire c'est à dire garder un brevet de
réformistes et c'est ça n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
en tout cas la retraite ça peut attendre
le prochain quinquennat en tout cas
selon vous est-ce qu'il a intérêt à
attendre la prochaine la la campagne
pour la présidentielle pour en parler
où ils risquent effectivement il risque
un mouvement social si jamais ils
l'annoncent ce soir vous voyez bien état
d'esprit des français ils sont inquiets
des prix mais eux parfois en colère et
on n'est pas très loin par dans
certaines zones de la population d'un
nouveau mouvement type il est jaune et c
est ce que c'est le moment alors que le
pays doit repartir du bon pied
alors que la reprise européenne et sans
doute possible est ce que c'est le
moment de remettre tout le monde dans la
rue pour un dossier
mon kiki qui se réglera avec le temps et
dont on sait que en fait c'est le
problème du chômage qui continue les
cotisations entre moins les impôts en
trombe
donc il faut attendre un peu un et il
faut surtout se consacrer à reprise
c'est très important parce qu'il faut
que je redevienne d'une humeur
acceptable vous savez dans paris où je
me promène beaucoup je crois intelligent
le l'état de déprime boire de coller est
manifestée par beaucoup de gens
l'impression de ne jamais venir à bout
le cep en demi puis aussi que n'avoir
aucune perspective pour demain est très
inquiétante je crois que le gouvernement
devrait se préoccuper de l'état moral de
la nation
parce que pour le moment on a
l'impression qu'il eu par moments qui
joue avec ses propres problèmes ses
propres fantasmes mais pas uniquement
l'opinion des points c'est qui compte
quand même pour diriger un pays qu'est
ce c'est quand même c'est quand même
important
alors l'état moral de la nation ce sera
peut être au menu ce soir à villeurbanne
puisque les des soutiens de dany d'al
gore n'a parlais à l'instant se
réunissent pour travailler sur un projet
politique plus de 200 maires élus locaux
l'appel à se présenter à la
présidentielle
et voyez ce qu'ils disent d'anne hidalgo
européenne a reconnu porte une vision
claire de notre société
riche de sa diversité apaisé mobiliser
face au défi climatique
sa capacité à gérer les crises
terroristes comme sanitaire a partout
été reconnue en france comme à
l'international où ses pairs l'ont porté
à la présidence des grandes villes du
monde
alors on le sait anne hidalgo aussi
critiqué pour sa gestion de paris
beaucoup lui reprochent d'avoir fait de
la capitale une ville sale un chantier
j'ai en quelque sorte pour autant à ce
que ce serait pour vous une bonne
candidate pour votre parti le parti
socialiste pour la prochaine
présidentielle
écoutez moi je me suis un peu éloigné
quand même du parti socialiste ces
derniers temps y compris aux élections
régionales je ne pense pas que ça soit
bien parti parce que d'abord les
sondages même si tout le monde il faut
pas y croire oui d'accord mais enfin
quand on est dans la zone des 5 6% ya
peu de chance qu'il faut c'est trouver
un camp
ida qui arrive à rassembler au-delà au
delà des partis est en tout cas au delà
du stricte obédience socialiste crois
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a compris
ça alors maintenant ils peuvent se
réunir il peut placer les boys peuvent y
a pas de problème je veux dire c'est
leur affaire
moi pour le moment je me sens pas très
motivé pour ça vous seriez pour des
primaires à gauche
non c'est une catastrophe les primaires
tout le monde le sait ça ne mène qu'à
accentuer les divisions et à exciter les
entourages qui sont la plaie de la
politique française
je crois qu'il faut petit à petit voir
se dessiner une possibilité aujourd'hui
c'est manifestement davantage la droite
républicaine qui peut menacer l'éternel
duel entre enfin éternel heureusement
pas entre eux
macron est la candidate du front
national du lourd à son nom nationale
pense qu'il faut à l'automne
il va falloir commencer à faire des
propositions parce qu'il suffit pas de
dire on est républicain on écologie
c'est senna à tout ça c'est avec qui
pour quoi faire et quelles sont les
options
quel type d'action on veut mener au
moment où à rien venir honnêtement rien
venir
il ya des candidats qui ont quelque
chose à dire sans doute à thonon qui
disent quelque chose pour le moment
laissons leur prendre des vacances alors
fera du bien merci beaucoup jean paul
huchon d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin dans la matinale de rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes ancien
président de la région ile de france
et ancien président parti socialiste du
conseil régional d'île de france